salut aujourd'hui on est mercredi c'est
donc le jour de l'astuce du mercredi je
sais que vous regardez le t-shirt j'ai
eu plein de messages dans les
commentaires depuis trois semaines on me
demande qu'est ce que c'est que ce
t-shirt alors je vous le faire voilà
c'est le fantôme qui en train d'essayer
de pas se faire manger par pac man
m'avait aussi demandé où est ce qu'on
pouvait l'acheter je peux pas vraiment
vous répondre en fait je l'achetais à
camden town c'est au nord de londres où
il ya plein plein de boutiques partout
c'est vraiment rigolo d'ailleurs tu peux
passer une journée une semaine même
juste là bas à te perdre dans les
boutiques et à dépenser tout ton argent
en même temps vous pouvez prendre
quelques minutes pour regarder la vidéo
de londres vous avez aussi posé une
question pour savoir si vous vouliez
plus d'astuces plus d'explications de
mentalisme je vous ai posé la question
dimanche on est aujourd'hui mercredi
voici ce que j'en ai retiré vous en
voudriez un petit peu plus mais pas trop
non plus alors comme quoi j'ai bien fait
de nous poser la question parce que
j'avais l'impression vous en vouliez
beaucoup plus d'explications donc je
vais trouver un juste milieu
à partir de samedi je vais lancer encore
un autre rendez vous sur youtube
je passe ma vie à créer des rendez vous
avec vous le samedi ce sera pas un
mental bloc comme les autres ce sera de
l'institut sont plus poussés
ce ne sera pas un cours c'est pas une
formation parce que je passe du tout la
prétention de vous former à quoi que ce
soit disons que la semaine j'essaie
quand même de faire des choses un peu
plus rapide un peu plus dynamique qu'on
assimile facilement je pense que le
samedi je vais pousser ça un petit peu
plus loin donc je filmerai le premier
depuis aix en provence puisque je suis
de mercredi jusqu'à dimanche à
aix-en-provence en café-théâtre la
fontaine d'argent d'ailleurs si tu veux
venir me voir et je vais appeler ça le
master class du samedi c'est un niveau
au-dessus de l'astuce ce sera des vidéos
un peu plus technique un peu plus longue
appliquée par tout le monde mais
forcément pour les appliquer il faudra
passer un petit moment à les écouter
voire même à s'entraîner voilà j'ai fait
mes petites annonces et vraiment je suis
étonné de cette réponse j'avais
l'impression que vous vouliez beaucoup
plus d'explications et tout comme quoi
ça vaut le coup que nous communiquions
ensemble continuer à mettre des
commentaires ou même simplement les
pouces en l'air en dessous la vidéo ça
me permet aussi de savoir que celle-ci
vous plaît particulièrement que sujet
vous plaît que le format vous plaît je
vous observe rare la webcam à travers le
logiciel espion que j'ai installé la
dernière fois que tu as laïque et ne
t'inquiète pas y'a rien d'installer tout
va bien inutile de te mettre du papier
d'aluminium autour de la tête
astuce du mercredi donc c'est en rapport
avec la mémoire ça je l'avais annoncé
du coup je vais pas parler durant des
heures vous expliquer le fonctionnement
de la mémoire etc
ça sera plus pour le samedi pour
lassitude je veux juste vous apprendre à
retenir un an
au téléphone facilement à la baule quand
vous donne un numéro de téléphone pour
le retenir vous le mettez dans votre
mémoire à court terme ou voir même à
très court terme tu la connais la
mémoire à très court terme c'est celle
où tu mets l'heure quand tu regardes ton
téléphone tu regarde l'heure tout leur
oppose à peine une seconde après si on
te demande l'heure tu fais je sais plus
je sais plus il faut que tu regarde à
nouveau c'est normal tu l'as mis dans ta
mémoire à très court terme et b tu fais
pareil pour les numéros de téléphone on
peut quand même le retenir dans la
mémoire à moyen terme facilement en
utilisant des moyens de mener mot
technique très simple je sais tu vas pas
attendu pour appliquer des moyens de
mener nos techniques pour retenir
quelque chose c'est sûr et certain mais
je vais rendre ça c'est peut-être un peu
plus efficace si je te donne un numéro
de téléphone au hasard 06 22 03 53 17
nous mettons n'appelle pas c'est pas
quelqu'un que je connais j'ai vraiment
de dire ça au pif pour le retenir
comment tu ferais tu sois tu veux
répéter en boucle
donc là on est toujours dans la mémoire
à court terme soit tu vas trouver des
petites astuces pour le mémoriser par
exemple si tu es né le 22 ski le cas
pour moi je suis né à 22 ça ça va me
marquer je vais trouver ça significatif
et je vais plus facilement m'en rappeler
mais tu peux prendre le temps de le
faire voir même d'imaginer une histoire
avec pour imaginer une histoire quand on
n'a pas l'habitude de faire travailler
son imaginaire je recommande de fermer
les yeux donc tu peux fermer les yeux
pour le faire sinon tu peux regarder la
vidéo en même temps il n'y a pas de
souci mais il faut développer ton
imaginaire pour bien fixer cette mémo
technique on a dit quoi 06 22 03 53 17
je crois que c'est ça que vous ayez un
instant vidéo sur la mémoire déjà je me
suis un peu de ce que j'ai dit champion
du monde
alors voici l'histoire que je propose
pour fixer ce mois téléphone 06 on
oublie tous les numéros de téléphone
commençant par 06 en général 22 c'est la
police 22 v'là les flics
ok donc imagine que tu as un policier il
tombe sur qui tombe sur les trois petits
cochons 03 hockey sur les trois petits
cochons donc on imagine le policier qui
marche et qui arrête les trois petits
cochons
les trois petits cochons ils ont quoi
dans les mains ils ont trois bouteilles
de pastis chacun ils ont chacun trois
bouteilles de pastis chacun ces trois
bouteilles de pastis ils viennent de les
voler d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'ils
arrivent donc on imagine le policier en
train d'arrêter les trois petits cochons
parce qu'ils étaient en train de
cambrioler trois bouteilles de pastis
chacun ça va jusque là je n'ai pas
encore perdu il imaginer que les trois
petits cochons s'enfuit avec leurs
bouteilles qu'ils arrivent à courir et
il se cache on se cache dans deux
grandes tours des deux grandes tours qui
a dans le port de la rochelle
la tour de la chaîne et la tour de la
lanterne pourquoi il se cache dans les
tours parce que la rochelle c'est la
chanterie méchante parking c'est le 17
on aurait pu aussi dire que en fait ils
s'aperçoivent que c'est un faux policier
que du coup ils décident eux-mêmes
d'appeler la police et compose le 17
ce qui nous donnerait aussi une saynète
cohérente puisqu'on aurait le policier
qui marchent ils tombent sur les trois
petits cochons qui sont en train de vous
les trois bouteilles de pastis 51 chacun
trois chacun ils leurs cours après pour
les arrêter les trois petits cochons de
vente que c'est un faux policier ils
appellent eux-mêmes la police pour
vérifier en prenant leur téléphone sénat
finale à fin août on est composé le 17
bienvenue dans mon monde pourquoi cette
scène là je vous le dis parce que au
départ 22 pour la police doit le
policier fait penser à 22 aux flics les
trois petits cochons parce que trois
donc 22 03 pourquoi trois bouteilles de
pastis alors ça c'est mon délire à moi
c'est à dire de 51 à 55 je pense
toujours une bouteille de pastis s'il de
bouteille c'est 50 de six à trois
bouteilles ses 53 s'il ya peut-être
bouteille 54,6 en à 5,55 et à la fin ils
ont rappelé la police donc 17 pour le
coup de fil à la police où ils se sont
cachés dans les tours de la rochelle
ce qui me fait penser au 17 pour la
charente maritime est ce que tu es en
train de comprendre comment on fait et
oui c'est assez simple à faire en fait
et j'aurais pu même associer la personne
à qui elle appartient le numéro de
téléphone en imaginant cette personne là
un policier
je te fais areca pour retenir ce numéro
de téléphone spécifique
j'aurais imaginé la personne à qui
appartient le numéro en policier dans ma
tête j'aurais imaginé en train de jouer
aux dés ensuite de se lever de la table
où elle joue aux dés et de tomber sur
les trois petits cochons en train de
chauray chacun trois bouteilles de
pastis 51 et ensuite j'aurai vu dans ma
tête toujours les 3 p'tits cochons
s'enfuir en courant pour se cacher dans
les tours de la rochelle et pour me
souvenir du numéro une heure après ou le
soir même pour le noter voire même le
lendemain parce que ça tient quelques
jours c'est du moyen terme
j'aurais juste à imaginer la personne et
à partir de là toute l'action qui en
découlent
elle me serais revenu parce qu'il ya une
logique en fait notre cerveau comme ça
et notre mémoire m se nourrir
d'imaginaire de choses logiques deux
choses cohérentes
elle aime pas trop l'abstrait elle
n'aime pas trop ce qui correspond à rien
elle aime bien les vraies images et tout
ce qui est incongru donc si vous vous
amusez à utiliser de la démo technique
avec un vrai temps de mémorisation et
d'imagination vous allez retenir les
numéros de téléphone
alors est ce que je vous recommande
c'est sur un temps mort par exemple en
voiture ou dans un train ou dans les
transports en commun peu importe
d'imaginer des images mentales des
accroches que vous pourriez avoir en
fait qu'est-ce que vous imagineriez pour
un pour deux pour trois pour quatre
experts jusqu'à 99
ça prend pas énormément de temps c'est
juste pour avoir fait au moins une fois
le travail d'imagination préalable que
vous soyez pas bloquée à cause d'un
chiffre en particules donc voici
l'astuce du mercredi pour retenir un
numéro de téléphone à moyen terme
vous essayez de trouver une démo
technique à chaque numéro une rapide une
qui vous paraît cohérente qui vous
correspond à vous ensuite vous
construisez une action une petite
saynète avec toutes ces images qui
passent une par une avec une action
logique ou une logique il faut qu'il y
ait un lien entre chaque image vous
associez si possible visage de la
personne dont vous voulez rire le numéro
et jusqu'au soir jusqu'au lendemain
voire au surlendemain voir une semaine
après pour les plus entraînés vous
souviendrez de ce numéro de téléphone le
but ce n'est pas de le retenir pour
toute la vie le but c'est de le retenir
assez longtemps pour pouvoir leur noté
ailleurs pour pouvoir le stocker sur un
laps de temps raisonnable avant de
pouvoir se décharger dans un calepin par
exemple voilà c'était l'astuce du
mercredi qui était un petit peu pesé sur
la mémoire j'espère que ça vous a plu
samedi il y aura donc le premier master
class car vous ne savez y perd
prétentieux mais de trop tard je
l'appeler comme ça maintenant six
manches pour l'explication est dit s'ils
allaient mentale blog comme tous les
jours ça va faire un rapport de 4 sur 3
entre le fait que vous êtes en train de
devenir des petits mentalise à terre et
le fait de vous faire voir mon quotidien
mentalist ans les gens que je rencontre
si cette nouvelle astuce vous a plu
mettez un pouce en l'air comme ça ça me
motive à en faire c'est très important
et abonnez-vous à la chaîne youtube
abonnez vous abonnez vous abonnez-vous
c'est moins compliqué que de retenir un
trou numéro de téléphone de s'abonner
petit clic et quitta bonne et je vous
dis à demain 17h pour le nouveau mental
vlog ciao